in problem-solving when we're working
with problems with potential and kinetic
energy remember we have our main concept
that the non-conservative work causes
the potential energy and kinetic energy
to change okay final minus K initial
plus u final minus u initial now how are
we going to apply this in
problem-solving well what we'd like to
introduce is a tool which we're going to
refer to as our energy state diagrams so
the way this works is we want let's have
an example to think about suppose you
have a dome so here's some dome we can
think of this as the MIT dome and you
have an object that is initially at the
top of the dome and then this object is
sliding down the dome and at a later
time it's at a point somewhere along the
dome now eventually it's going to fall
off the dome but that's a separate
question so how can we use our energy
ideas to analyze this situation and the
way we do it is that we choose first
initial and final States that we're in
considering because our first idea in
the energy diagram is to compare the
change in energy kinetic energy between
the initial and change a potential
energy between the initial and the final
States
so in our dome problem we would choose
our initial state let's
draw our object at the top and in our
final state separately let's draw the
object over here and then we want to
parameterize these states by some type
of coordinate system so here we're gonna
have some type of coordinate system that
we'll use for both energies of scalars
so we don't have to worry about it and
what I'll do is I'll define an angle
theta final here from the vertical here
theta initial is 0 and I've now
parameterize my initial and final States
now the important thing that we'll do in
the energy diagram is to draw is to
choose our zero potential energy where
are we going to choose this so we could
say either a surface we'll call that
potential energy and in this diagram I
can choose by zero for potential energy
anywhere I want but I want to draw it on
my initial in my final States so I'm
going to choose it right here and I'll
denote this as U equals zero and now I
can now make a list of I want to
identify so step three is to identify
the K and you for each state so here we
have K initial it's at rest zero and u
initial well I didn't introduce a
parameter R it's u initial is how high
the gravitational potential energy so in
this particular case mg times R now over
here K final is one-half M V final
squared and u final we can denote it
here if I plot this out and that's R and
you can see that this is our cosine
theta final so that's mg R cosine theta
final now the fourth step is to identify
w non-conservative is there any non
conservative work now here let's assume
the dome is frictionless and that means
that W non conservative is 0 and our
last step 5 is we can apply the energy
principle which is W non conservative
equals Delta K let's write it out
everything explicit now that we've
defined K final minus K initial plus u
final minus u initial and you see the
power of these diagrams is and this
methodology is we've now defined very
explicitly every single term that
appears in the energy principle and so
we can write out our result that 0 K
final one-half M V final squared K
initial 0 plus u final mg R cosine theta
final minus u initial mg R and there we
have applied the energy principle using
the tool of energy diagrams